what's going on guys this is Rob we are
back with X-Men red and the Genesis war
and
storm Jesus storm dude the ending of
this is crazy okay so before we get to
the storm portion we do have to cover
this first tidbit and this is the return
of Gabriel Summers also known as Vulcan
not only is the return of Gabriel
Summers as Vulcan he's back to his full
power now for those of you guys who
don't know what that means Gabriel
Summers is an Mega level mutant this guy
can manipulate and control any form of
energy in existence it doesn't matter
what it is cosmic energy right this guy
is one Marvel writer away from being
able to alter reality on a universal
scale and given how his powers work it's
entirely possible but Gabriel Summers
has been brought back by Apocalypse Now
in the last video that we did we talked
about how apocalypse had gone and
rescued Sunfire who was kind of like one
of the mutant variance or kind of
equivalents to Johnny Storm from the
Fantastic Four right Sunfire and Sunspot
are actually almost identical in terms
of power just varying degrees of how hot
they can get no pun
intended but the thing about this is
that when Gabriel Summers is brought
back by apocalypse and his full powers
are restored the question he asked is am
I to be your death now this is not him
asking the question am I to be the one
that kills you anybody who's familiar
with apocalypse known He Has His Four
Horsemen right War pestilence famine and
death that's his thing whenever he
brings mutants into his service or even
non- mutants into his service he grants
them the title of one of his four
horsemen that's the question Gabriel
Summers is asking am I to be your
Horseman death well the cool thing is
apocalypse says no Gabriel Summers you
are not on any level in times past I
ordained My Chosen warriors with the
names of those I had lost and wrote
their names in blood in the sacred texts
of humankind but now now is a time for
older Concepts had my family understood
my path this would be a simple matter
but it is happening as it must it is
happening now and I do not need a new
death so he's planning something
entirely new what he's man the ending
the man the ending of this is absolutely
crazy what he's planning here is
mindblowing right it's awesome right
right so he says I need the fire to be
fire I need you to be you now here's the
difference between someone like
apocalypse and someone like Gabriel
Summers is Gabriel Summers powerful yes
is Gabriel Summers as powerful as
apocalypse no and the reason why is
because apocalypse immediately says but
fire is only useful when harnessed so
you will remain bound to me and bound to
my will obligation is a useful
ingredient in the old Magics and their
confines will teach you restraint he
immediately harnesses this guy's power
right like basically your ability to use
your powers is relative to whether or
not I choose to allow you to use them on
me that's it you can attack anybody but
me he overrides the ability of Gabriel
Summers to use his abilities to attack
apocalypse that's the kind of power he
possesses now one of the things that I
do want to point out here and this is
especially prominent with what Jonathan
Hickman is doing right now with the
God's comic that he's covering but also
Al a lot of the old stuff when it comes
to Magic in Marvel Comics this is a
universal concept that most anybody can
tap into if they can somehow harness the
fortitude to do it not everybody can and
nine times out of 10 people who practice
quote unquote magic in Marvel are either
people who are using things like slide
of hand and deception or if they are
using genuine magic they're only using a
very low-level form of it it's the
reason why you don't have like 100,000
doctor Stranges running around the
Marvel Universe not everyone can attain
power on that scale because they simply
just don't have the aptitude for it but
apocalypse has been around for an
incredibly long time thousands of years
and so while his ability to harness
magic is nowhere near the same level as
Steven strange it is on a level to where
he can use old magic and even new magic
for a variety of different purposes
that's one of the things that makes
apocalypse so incredibly powerful this
guy just by virtue of the abilities that
he has right he can grow and Shrink to
any size he can give himself any
superhuman power he's Immortal right all
that kind of stuff he's not
indestructible but assuming that you
can't destroy his physical form he will
just live forever right like the ability
to harness and practice magic that's
something that he's been doing for a
very long time that's not new it's just
an aspect of his abilities that you
don't see very often but what you have
here is when Gabriel Summers is brought
back to the other people people that
apocalypse has gathered right the demon
that he brought with him from the realm
of araku right the other dimension where
he' resided for quite some time along
with Sunfire their question is so what's
the point here right like what's the
deal with all of this right because
apocalypse starts talking in his like
ceremonial talk right like yes the oet
you strained against for months which
you welld deserve destroyer of worlds I
tore easily with bare hands like just
the apocalypse speak right you know like
I mean usually it's cool when spinning
out one liners you like I am the rocks
on the Eternal Shore crash against me
and be broken you know like that kind of
thing that's cool but Sunfire is just
like not having it right so he's like
let's skip the wh ifs man like we're
here now and what is this that we're
seeing going on you need Magical
elements fire earth air water what's the
point of all of this and so it's one of
these things where when the question
when Sunfire brings up the point in
saying I'm guessing that like Storm's
the the air and whatever it is that
you're doing the response of Apocalypse
is no storm is not a mere ingredient in
this magic Aurora is the magic and so
that's the crazy thing because at that
point you transition over to storm now
here's the thing as those of you guys
who know from following our coverage of
X-Men red so far storm has been
contending with the uranos trigger right
little bit of a reminder here for those
of you guys who forgot uranos is just a
ridiculously powerful Eternal the deal
that was struck between the eternals and
the ex men following the Avengers versus
X-Men versus eternals Judgment Day event
is that because uranos was released by
The eternals on Mars where a huge
portion of mutants resided and that
within the span of one hour he had
eradicated pretty much
99% of all mutants on the planet that
the uranos trigger would allow the
mutant population to release uranos for
their own accord if they needed to
Storm's been contending with this it was
presented to her right like this is an
option of available to you and that's
where uranos asked the question what
will your decision be which Massacre
will you choose whatever your answer it
is on your head you have company by the
way because uranos is able to kind of
read her mind and see what's going on
around her but make no mistake right
uranos is an old like he's the old
eternals not the new ones not Icarus
right not any of those guys who were
just like capable he's the old eternals
right like OG double OG ridiculously
overpowered like uranos versus Thanos
right Thanos would get those cheeks
clapped and it wouldn't even be close
and so storm pondering over this whole
thing John ironfire right kind of like
her number two right her top General
comes to her and says you need to
release uranos if you do that he will
end this Genesis War immediately right
he will end this whole thing right now
but storm chooses not to right she says
no right when John says someone has to
end it and if you're not strong enough I
will storm destroys the uranos trigger
and that's when os's last words to her
are your choice I hope you don't regret
it and so John just kind of freaks out
and he's like what have you done right
like that was the end of the war that
was our Victory and Storm's response is
that was genocide right and his answer
is it was Mercy right it was the
Innocence under Annihilation spell or
all the Innocence here Genesis is coming
aoro do you know who she is because I do
I lived alongside her in a paradise of
Art and freedom and love and she feared
it the hund fought to make okara whole
again she fought to break it apart
further and if you think Annihilation is
using her somehow I tell you that she is
using it planting her damned Whispers in
the minds of anyone she thinks is useful
no matter what they believed before and
the response of storm here this is
incredibly important here why she says
and how is that different different from
your general once he commanded you are
you beholden to his whims now now she's
responding and talking about the white
sword right for those you guys who don't
remember that guy because we haven't
talked about him for a long time the
white sword and his 100 the white sword
has the ability to heal himself and
anybody else and even resurrect himself
and anybody else from the dead that's
why him and his soldiers are called the
100 and that's why they're the most
feared forces in seemingly all of
creation because fighting against an
enemy that can never truly die is an
enemy that you can never truly defeat
and so that's where things get really
cool because in turn you basically have
Robert dasta who comes along and
basically tells storm you could stop him
you know and she says not without
killing him because iron fire is a
Believer right he is a True Believer and
so what happens is of course storm is
basically taken before Richard Ryder
Nova because again in the last video we
talked about how Richard Ryder is kind
of a liaison for the mutant population
with regards to like the other Empires
that exist out there in the universe but
he had basically taken an arrow from
pestilence in order to keep Storm from
dying right but again pestilence
representing plague it's spreading
throughout Richard Ryder's body and so
the world mind of the novacore is
keeping him alive using its power and
trying to fight off the infection but
there's seemingly no real way to do it
and the cool thing about this is that in
this conversation that storm and Robert
to have right like Robert Acosta says he
didn't take that Arrow so you could
press some kill a million mutants button
and the response to storm is no he
didn't Richard Ryder knew that there
would be no button right this is the
kicker to this this is what storm means
when she says this what she's basically
saying is sure uranos could have come
here he could have ended the war by
eradicating the entirety of Genesis
forces thereby ending the Genesis War
but the reality here is that if all I
wanted to do was lay waste to an entire
world raise it to the ground and
annihilate her forces I would have done
that already I would have already done
that that's what storm is saying and
that's why I love the way that aling is
handling her forces because it's true I
love the way that aling is handling
storm people don't like that's the thing
man like I feel like a lot of people who
are familiar with storm don't really
understand the nature of storm in Marvel
Comics they're starting to get it now
man because storm this girl is a
wrecking machine right this this girl is
death incarnate like this this chick
right being able to command an entire
like weather system I mean if this was
really storm wanting to eradicate the
forces of Genesis she would summon
endless tornadoes lightning storms that
would stretch the entirety of the planet
that would superheat the entirety of the
atmosphere right that would literally
just turn the entire world into an
uninhabitable grave that's what she
would do this is a woman with a power to
kill a world that's what storm has the
ability to do and that's why it's so
cool because at that moment apocalypse
shows up now this is the cool thing when
apocalypse emerges here you immediately
have the conversation between himself
and storm because for the most part the
last time storm saw apocalypse was at
the conclusion of 10 of Swords event
when we learn that before there was the
island of ccoa and there was the island
of oraco out in this other dimension
that they were once a singular island
called okara and that the island had to
basically be separated to stop the
Demonic forces of annihilation from
invading the rest of all of creation
right in order to ensure that the portal
like the rift could be closed that these
two Realms could basically live in peace
right they could live separate from each
other that those who chose to stay in
the dimension of Oro could choose to
stay there and those who chose to stay
within the Earthly Dimension could
choose to be there as well apocalypse
went to oraco he went to this other
dimension but when Genesis made her her
move left the Oro Dimension and then
invaded Mars with the intention of
taking over the entirety of the mutant
population within the main Marvel
Universe on Earth and on Mars that's
when apocalypse has been making his
return the response that he gives storm
here right when she says you don't stand
with Genesis his answer is I will not
stand against her but neither will I
stand aside her this world needs and
deserves more than she offers it needs
magic it needs you apocalypse is still
playing both sides right survival of the
fittest that only those who are strong
enough deserve to survive and so that's
why what he's doing here is he's saying
if this is going to be a fight between
you and Genesis and Genesis represents
the dimension of oraco and you represent
the dimension of kcoa then you guys
should fight as such and so as the two
of them are talking apocalypse makes the
recognition in saying uranos stays in
his bottle which is disappointing cuz I
kind of wanted to to see apocalypse
fight uranos to be honest with you guys
right and of course storm says he
offered the illusion of Clean Hands the
lie that I could summon evil and not
claim it the blood on my hands I accept
but they must be my hands and at least I
know when to stop right the response of
Apocalypse is yes yes that's what we
tell ourselves right it's really kind of
him saying the smart move would have
been to unleash uranos on Mars that
would have been the smart move because
the lie that you're telling yourself is
that you would have been able to stop
that if you just let your powers run
loose right you bring fire from the gods
down to the surface of Mars and you
eradicate all of Genesis forces that you
would be able to simply just stop there
right once the last of forces were
destroyed you'd be able to relinquish
all of this power right or at least
everything that you've done kind of sit
down take a deep sigh and say we won yay
celebrate right like the end of Return
of the Jedi no the reality is that you
would get carried away with it you would
get carried away with the power that you
have and you would become the darkest
version of yourself which really kind of
begs the question what would happen if
storm turned evil which I kind of want
to see right but apocalypse says I offer
a different choice but no Illusions the
forces of Genesis are coming for your
people perhaps even now and her response
is then I trust my people and in this I
trust you and apocalypse makes this
amazing response he says trust can be a
liar I trusted that my children would
one day stand at the four point
of this ex but they have not learned
what they needed to learn death shows
some promise but pestilence is lost
right dead basically and the rest are
not suitable so I must work with those
whom Fate has provided and so that's
when Sunfire makes his presence known
and that's when apocalypse brings
everybody together now here's a cool
thing about Vulcan right Gabriel Summers
here's a cool thing about him right like
once he sees storm he immediately freaks
right like you imprison me here buried
me alive under Solid Rock the response
to storm is only ccoa gave you amnesty
Gabriel the billions dead at your hands
would call what we did Mercy now there's
a couple things that she's referencing
here one is the role he played in the
events of uh Judgment day but the bigger
role that she's talking about here is
the old Gabriel Summers Gabriel Summers
when he was Vulcan that's what she's
talking about here that's what she means
when she says ccoa gave you am y for
those of you guys who don't know the
history of Gabriel and the full power
that he possesses in a story called
X-Men deadly Genesis as well as uh the
rise and fall of the shiar Empire story
arc that Vulcan had basically returned
after having believed to have been dead
he was actually saved by Darwin who was
a mutant but the point is that he had
returned and he had believed that he had
either been replaced lie to what have
you but when he was given his actual
origin that his mother was killed at the
hands of Deen of the shiar Empire he
immediately set out right like him
taking off to the shiar Empire that was
in the rise and fall of the shiar Empire
he conquered the entirety of it and then
went to war with the Inhumans in War of
Kings right so like waged the war
against the universe itself countless
billions were dead at his hands right
like the guy was just this crazy
fanatical warlord it was amazing like it
was just one of the coolest moments ever
in the history of his character that's
what she's refer ing here and so that's
why he says once I'm free of this blue
freak I'll make those billions seem like
fractions that's my Mercy which is true
because he could right like he could
eradicate everybody on Earth in one Fell
Swoop he simply just chooses not to but
apocalypse responds and he says and
everything that has died will live stand
in the center auror and that's when he
cast The Magic right he says Genesis
First Act in this war was to return what
had seemed dead the living Island orocco
to win this war you must answer that act
like for like this is the mutant magic
the highest mutant technology Let the
Fire be fire let the air be free let the
earth support the people and let water
reshape this world you are what brings
us together you are the weather the play
of the breeze and the fall of the rain
you are the storm you are the breath of
life and the breath of life is in you
and so as you live so does the land now
let the living land be born right and so
what you do is you switch over to
Genesis right basically alongside uh
soar right who's kind of like this
mutant that has the ability to
communicate with water and all that kind
of stuff doesn't really matter the point
is that as they're having this
conversation Genesis is kind of
relishing in the fact that they' pushed
the forces of storm back
right that Victory is near it's on the
horizon it's right there but right there
and what's on the horizon is also
something else because soar tells her
something is waiting through my blood
through the ocean towards us I can feel
it it's big enough for me to feel it and
when her response is what he says I can
feel it here look look points out there
and it's just this gigantic Island right
the rest is here here and it walks like
a mutant behold karck this literal
gigantic landmass through storm a
massive island has been created and it's
operating at storms entire wiim which
really begs the question what response
could Genesis possibly have for this
right like it's crazy because storm says
Genesis you claim to speak for oraco
then raise your Island and fight with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end I am excited to see
where this goes and I will catch you all
later peace